coronavirus cases are rising across
the whole of wales in a short number of
weeks
three small clusters of cases of the new
delta variant
have multiplied rapidly yesterday alone
over a thousand
new cases of coronavirus were reported
across wales
this fast-moving variant is in every
part of our country
and spreading quickly it is the dominant
form
of the virus in wales just as it has
become
a dominant form in the united kingdom
and in many other countries in europe
there can be no doubt but that we are
experiencing
the anticipated third wave of this
pandemic with the rate in wales
rising overnight to 145 cases
per 100 000 people
in a moment i will set out some reasons
for greater optimism
in dealing with this third wave than
either of its predecessors
but i wanted to leave members in no
doubt at
all that community prevalence
on this scale brings with it a set of
real dangers
that no responsible government or senate
should ignore our technical advisory
group
now says that the prevalence of
infection in wales
will remain extremely high for at least
the rest of this summer that level of
circulation of the virus will
increase the risk of new variants
emerging
increase the risk of the virus
re-entering hospitals care homes
and other closed settings it will
increase the risk
that the virus will move from younger to
older people
repeating the pattern of both waves one
and two it will increase the number of
people suffering
from long covet it will increase
workforce
absences including in our key public
services and it will place greater
strain
on our test trace protect service
and the genomic sequencing service
making the identification
of new variants more difficult
what then with other countervailing
factors
well first and foremost vaccination
and particularly our high rates of
vaccination in wales
is changing our relationship with the
virus and doing so faster
than any other uk nation
today more than 73 percent of all adults
in wales
have received two doses of the vaccine
the figure in england and scotland is 66
and it is 65 in northern ireland
the rising tide of cases has not
translated into higher rates of serious
illnesses
hospital admissions and deaths in the
same way it did
during the first wave or in the winter
and that
is because of vaccination
i want to put on record again my thanks
to all those people
who have worked so hard to plan and run
this highly successful program
the second way in which the position is
more promising
in this third wave is the way we have
lived uh
and that has left some positive legacy
the ons weekly estimate states that of
all the four home nations
wales has the highest level of acquired
immunity and that now stands at 92
percent
of the whole population thirdly we have
the defense of the ttp system
in the week ending the third of july 95
percent of index cases eligible for
follow-up
were contacted within 24 hours and 93
of their contacts were traced
so if that is the context in which the
cabinet has completed
our three weekly review of coronavirus
restrictions
our assessment is that taking all these
factors
negative and positive together we can
now proceed to a full
level one set of regulations
and this means that from the 17th of
july from saturday
up to six people will be able to meet
indoors in private homes and holiday
accommodation
organized indoor events for
up to 1000 people seated or 200 people
standing
will be able to take place following a
risk assessment
and that ice rinks will be able to
reopen
and we believe we can go a step further
as we move to the new alert
level zero and that we will be able to
introduce
alert level zero levels of restrictions
for outdoor events and gatherings also
from the 17th of july
we will therefore remove the limits on
the number of people who can gather
outdoors outdoor premises and events
will have more flexibility around
physical distancing
this will continue though to be one of
the mitigations
to be considered in carrying out and
implementing
risk assessments we are able to
do this because of our long-standing
conclusion
that the risk of transmission outdoors
is much lower than indoors and because
we need to take advantage of the summer
period at the same time from the 17th of
july
the regulations will also change to
allow up to 30 people from organizations
such as the earth brownies or scouts to
attend
residential centers over
the summer holidays
so with today we are also publishing an
updated version of our coronavirus
control plan
which sets out more broadly how we can
move beyond the current
alert level one to a new alert
level zero the cabinet's intention
is that whales should move to alert
level zero
on the seventh of august provided
the public health position in three
weeks time still
allows us to do so and i emphasize today
as i always do
the importance of that proviso
in a position where public health
challenges remain so
volatile we will assess and reassess the
position
on the 7th of august but with the
intention
that will should move to alert level 0
provided the public health position
remains as it is today
at alert level zero we have focused on
retaining those restrictions which help
people to keep safe but have the
smallest
detrimental effect on their wider
physical
and emotional health at level zero
therefore
there will be no legal limits on the
number of people who can meet
others including in private homes
public places or at events
and at alert level zero all businesses
and premises will be open so with life
will have returned very substantially
to how it was before the coronavirus
pandemic
began but here in wales
we will not abandon all those measures
which have done so much to keep us all
safe at alert level zero
and from the seventh of august therefore
people should continue
to work from home wherever possible
where a return to the workplace is
necessary we will continue to ensure
that
covet risk assessments will be a legal
requirement for businesses employers
and event organizers it will be a legal
requirement that these assessments
are drawn up with the involvement of
employees
and the mitigating measures set out
in those risk assessments must be
implemented
in wales as well flowers at alert
level zero face coverings will continue
to be a legal requirement
on public transport in health and care
settings
and in all indoor public places
with the exception of education settings
and hospitality
and the aim of the government will be
gradually to ease these
requirements as the risk of coronavirus
decreases uh finally s i turned
to further changes to self-isolation
requirements
i much regret the decision of the uk
government
to remove the requirement for doubly
vaccinated travelers returning from
ambulance countries to south isolate
the risk of re-importation of
coronavirus
from other parts of the world and
especially
new variants has not gone away
the removal of a defense against that
risk
and especially at a time when the virus
is
in such rapid circulation is very
difficult to understand but because the
vast majority of international travel
to and from wales is via england
it is as our chief medical officer says
untenable for us not to do
the same thing we will therefore remove
the requirement for all adults who have
had two
nhs coveted vaccines and for under 18
year olds
to self-isolate on their return from
ambulance countries
and we will remove those requirements
from the 19th of
july however we continue
to advise against all but essential
travel
abroad and we continue to strongly
recommend
people to holiday at home this
summer i turn out to the position
in relation to domestic self isolation
here the cabinet has decided that during
the next three week cycle which begins
on the 7th of august
we will remove the requirement for
people who have been fully vaccinated
to self isolate if they are a close
contact of someone
who has tested positive there is still
work to be done
before these changes can come into force
for example in adjusting our ttp system
and putting in place arrangements for
those who work
in health and care settings
self-isolation will continue to play a
very important role
in breaking the chain of transmission
for anyone who has symptoms of the virus
anyone who tests positive and anyone
who has not had two doses of
the vaccine so with coronavirus has not
gone away whatever the coming weeks and
months hold
the simple measures which have helped us
to keep us
all safe throughout the pandemic will
continue
to protect us all keeping your distance
meeting outdoors being in
well-ventilated places avoiding crowded
places where possible wearing a face
covering where it's not
and good hand hygiene
or villain a camel i can i see mill if
we follow these simple steps
we can work together to keep coronavirus
under control and prevent this third
wave
from growing too high
all of the evidence suggests that new
variants which may not respond
to the vaccines are more likely
to emerge when cases of coronavirus
are at high levels it remains
vital that we continue to
work together to keep
each other safe and to keep wales
safe as well